any trash talking from Connor as have I
missed it he's not doing any press he's
not oh [ __ ]
he's not doing anything figured it out
you figured out the promotion on your
own
seriously yes what about a countdown
cheb eight I think he basically said
listen man I'm gonna fight and that's it
that's what's gonna happen
October 6 I'm gonna fight and that's it
I might even like for the promotion I'd
like to think he's done man no he's hit
that plate first of all he just won a
hundred million dollars he probably
thinks you could suck all the dicks I'm
here right now if you want milk I want
to fight that's what I want to do I
don't want to do any year [ __ ] I
want to fight so on October 6 I'm gonna
show up and fight figure out all the
rest on October 5th I'll be there to
make weight in his accent though I wish
I could I'd have to listen to him a few
more times
if he dies he dies then it says hold I
go back down
you know if he dies he dies then I'm
paid twice 1.3 million like what does
that mean yeah it's a lot of likes yeah
he's trying to stay relevant he's trying
to put some words out there look sexy
probably got someone to doing it for him
some little assistant and you know he's
probably concentrate on the fight and
they said Connors is good and he's like
yeah that's [ __ ] good put it up I'll
tell you what man I can't [ __ ] wait
for that fight and you know you know if
one of them drop out hmm
you know tell me Hardison yeah twenty
Ferguson's ready to go ready to go and
he's on the card anyway and the
undercard against Pettis right yeah so
they would definitely do Ferguson in our
Pettis uh I think so I'm not sure I
think did they offer Norma Chamitoff to
Pettis when all that [ __ ] was going down
in New York in Brooklyn I know they
offered it to they were gonna have it
yes uh but chiesa got cut right
and they wouldn't they didn't let Paul
Felder because Paul Felder wasn't ranked
high enough which is crazy yeah they let
al Iaquinta do it but there's I think
they offered his report was Pettis and
felt or both denied mmm interesting
edison Felder both denied well
you know Pettis just beat chiesa by
triangle he looked good he looked like
he's back that I don't I I selfishly
hope that uh no one drops out because
first of all I want to see that fight
but two I really want to see Tony versus
Pettis yeah that's a that's a really
interesting fight man yeah Tony's
looking good man I bet he's looking good
it's amazing how quick he came back from
that surgery it's amazing man it's
amazing he's looking really good he's
breakdancing
I watched him break down swing this guy
just blew his knee ligaments off his
bones quit drinking no more drink and
he's clean as [ __ ] his diets and he
looks great right now
he looks why right yeah he's in he's in
tremendous shape how much was he's in
for the best shape of his life uh you
know a couple beers here in there you
know I mean no big deal but he's uh but
he said [ __ ] none of that oh dude that
injury just changed everything for him
that injuries like it just made him
re-evaluate his life and now he's coming
back stronger than ever man